this is a pot of cool water
and this is a pot of boiling water we've
all heard the analogy
place a frog in the boiling water and
he'll jump right out
but place him in the cool water and
slowly bring the water to boil
and the frog won't know he's boiling
till it's too late
and that in a nutshell is modern
american policing
it's how we got from here first put on
his new uniform
to here
[Music]
now this did not happen overnight
a series of major historical events
transpired
laws were passed and decades of slow
cultural shifts
brought us to this boiling point
they're literally pointing guns at us
and now that we're in the hot water
the question is how do we jump out
[Music]
this is professor peter b kraska he
wrote one of the most popular and cited
studies
on police militarization militarism is
basically at its heart a
problem-solving ideology it says that
the best way to solve problems that you
have in front of you
is to use uh violence
and military type weaponry and the
threat
of that violence to solve the problem
and that's what we're seeing in today's
police institution
generally speaking police militarization
has been seen as a problem in developing
nations
but concern has increasingly turned to
the united states on both sides of the
aisle
here's a massive study done by none
other than charles koch of the koch
brothers
about this very topic and why we should
all be concerned
but this is not an exclusively modern
problem
its roots can be traced all the way back
to the original colonies
the earliest form of policing in america
were slave patrols
the first of which were established in
1704.
this is historian and author professor
sally hadden
the slave patrols are what we might
think of as pre-policing
their job was a combination of social
control
and racial control to try to
enforce the the norms that the white
community wanted to see
in place they were created to try to
restrain
slaves from behaviors that the white
community
did not approve of they had guns they
had dogs they had whips
[Music]
once slavery was ended across the south
slave patrols were effectively replaced
by white community leaders with either
police forces
or a little bit later with vigilante
groups
such as the ku klux klan northern troops
were often tasked with policing southern
states during the reconstruction era
and president rutherford b hayes was
accused of using the military
as a political tool to bust unions sway
elections
and quell civil unrest
scores of protesters were killed and
injured during the great railroad strike
of 1877.
the following year congress passed the
posse comitatus act
making it illegal to use any part of the
us military
as law enforcement not many people are
talking about posse comitatus anymore
it's very
relevant if someone cares about one of
the key tenets of democratic governance
is a clear distinction
between the military which focuses on
external threats
and the police which serves the
democratic citizenry
of the united states and have a bright
clear line between those
that bright clear line blurred gradually
over the course of three american wars
not those three these three
the first point of the frog being boiled
was the social unrest of the 1960s
as a response to growing inner city
violence president lyndon johnson
declared a war on crime
and signed the law enforcement
assistance act in 1965.
a 30 million dollar program provided
police departments across the country
with bulletproof vests helicopters tanks
rifles gas masks and other tactical gear
less than one month later the watts
riots
shocked america and left 34 people dead
los angeles police chief william h
parker characterized the riots as an
insurgency
and decreed a paramilitary response to
the disorder
fourteen thousand national guardsmen
joined the police
in trying to maintain order on the
streets
three years later the country was in a
state of complete turmoil
martin luther king was shot and was
killed tonight
the assassination of martin luther king
jr triggered riots across
major cities in america especially in
chicago
the show of force was staggering 10 500
police
over 6 hundred national guard troops and
five thousand soldiers from the first
armored and fifth infantry divisions
patrolled the streets president johnson
declared a state of emergency that
declaration resulted in the virtually
unthinkable act of armed regular army
troops deployed to protect the capital
in the white house
just a few months later after the
assassination of bobby kennedy
protesters clashed violently with police
forces during the democratic national
convention
and all of it was televised
it was over this tumultuous period that
swat teams were first formed
as part of a larger police effort to
militarize responses to riots
and other types of civil unrest even
though that was its
genesis the real cause of today's police
militarization
was the reagan bush and then clinton
drug wars
i believe this program will prove to be
a highly effective
attack on drug trafficking in 1981
president ronald reagan signed the
military cooperation with civilian law
enforcement agencies act
the line between the military and law
enforcement continued to blur
as police forces received increasing
monetary and tactical assistance
and for the first time swat teams became
a regular part
of law enforcement operations
a decade later as the drug wars dragged
on with no victory in sight
president george walker bush launched
the 1033 program
this cleared a frictionless path for the
department of defense to issue
massive amounts of military gear and
battlefield weaponry
to local law enforcement it's worth
noting that all this gear
was and remains to this day free to any
police department that takes part in the
program
all they have to do is pay for shipping
costs
let us roll up our sleeves to roll back
this awful tide of violence
and reduced crime in our country the
clinton administration
expanded the 1033 program after a north
hollywood bank robbery in 1997.
the two bank robbers dressed in heavy
body armor and carrying
automatic assault rifles simply
outgunned the lapd
this coupled with incidents like the
columbine shooting and escalated gun
violence all around
made it painfully clear that the police
needed to be better prepared for the
type of arms that the general public had
easy access to
we have seen in the last 25 years
an internal arms race
[Music]
we've seen the police arming themselves
and the people arming themselves at an
unprecedented level
the first plane hit the first of the
world trade center towers at 8
50 thereabouts eastern time
one world trade center has collapsed
in its entirety one world trade center
is gone
the second tower just collapsed we will
work closely with our coalition
to deny terrorists and their state
sponsors the materials
technology and expertise to make and
deliver
weapons of mass destruction the war on
terror
really created a new environment for
policing where
there was this this tangible threat that
they
all had to be aware of and so under the
auspices of preparing for terrorism
we saw a real acceleration of police
militarization
you had all of these police officers
going through
training camps for-profit training camps
funded by doj
and dhs and getting this weaponry
since 1990 law enforcement agencies have
received over 6 billion
in military hardware from the department
of defense
between 2006 and 2014 alone the dod
transferred 600 mine resistant armored
vehicles
79 288 assault rifles
205 grenade launchers almost 12 000
bayonets
50 airplanes 422 helicopters
and 3.6 million dollars worth of
tactical clothing
to 80 percent of all the nation's local
law enforcement offices
much of this arsenal was transferred
directly from the middle east into u.s
police precincts
especially after 2011 when president
barack obama
began pulling troops out of iraq
and now you see police unashamed to
wear full battle dress utilities
to pursue problems with a militaristic
approach
go into neighborhoods and occupy them as
if
they're doing some sort of counter
insurgency
and fully embrace the military model
and this brings us to an element perhaps
even more important than the gear
it's best understood by applying a
classic psychological term
called the law of the instrument so if
you have a hammer in your hand
everything begins to look like a nail
police departments have the technology
of a swat team
they have the armament of the military
you're going to want to use this stuff
it plays into warrior fantasies
it gives an imagery that's really
intoxicating to a
segment of the police institution
what little data there is supports these
claims
swat style no knock raids have increased
by 1400
since 1980. this is partly because swat
raids on low level offenders
are actually used as training exercises
but the key thing to remember
it's not the swat teams anymore it's how
the ideology and the armament and the
tactical
approach has now dispersed throughout
the entire
police institution
[Applause]
reaction to the grand jury's decision
left destruction in the streets of
ferguson this morning the grand jury
decided not to charge
officer darren wilson in the shooting
death of michael brown
it wasn't until ferguson that the rest
of the united states of america
finally woke up to the kinds of things
that were going on in policing
so it came to a boiling point
in response to ferguson president barack
obama issued an audit of american
policing
and signed an executive order scaling
back the 1033 program
we've seen how militarized gear
can sometimes give people a feeling like
there's an occupying force as opposed to
a force that's part of the community
that's protecting them and serving them
but his actions did nothing to curb the
myriad other means of acquiring tactical
gear
nor did it address the larger problem of
militarized police culture
and what little obama may have
accomplished was reversed two years
later when attorney general jeff
sessions on behalf of president donald
trump lifted the executive order he is
rescinding restrictions
from the prior administration that
limited your agency's ability
to get equipment through federal
programs including
life-saving gear
which pretty much brings us to today
[Music]
george floyd's killing at the hands of
the minneapolis police department
prompted mass protests
[Applause]
we're moving here
calls for reform from reducing police
funding to disbanding precincts
altogether
became rallying cries nationwide
i took the helmet off and laid the
batons down public pressure has moved
the needle on this issue and cities like
camden new jersey
have become representative of a new
community-focused policing model
but across the nation the die remains
cast
and president trump has taken a
decidedly divisive approach on the
matter
june 1st finally gave us a hallmark
moment to really demonstrate
the unequivocal support trump has been
giving police militarization
tensions only escalated after trump's
photo op and the assault by soldiers on
peaceful protesters
at the behest of attorney general
william barr portland oregon was flooded
with unidentified forces
dressed as soldiers what is going on who
are you
detaining demonstrators in unmarked
vehicles and even assaulting
peaceful protesters
[Music]
lawsuits have already been filed over
these arguably shocking acts of violence
by federal agents against american
citizens
but that hasn't stopped president trump
from threatening further federal
deployments to other major cities
escalating tensions between police
forces and the citizens they're supposed
to serve
the frog is boiled it's not even noticed
the police wouldn't even recognize the
word police militarization
because it's just something they are
part of
and live with and they really do scratch
their head often times
as to where this critical thinking is
coming